so we've done a ton of deep dives and
policy centric stuff over the last few
days we did a nearly 20 minute segment
on fiscal and monetary policy yesterday
we are going to be talking later today
about a good versus a bad clinical trial
for a medication how randomized clinical
trials work the importance of placebo
placebo how vaccinations are developed
and researched let's do a brief
interlude from that because the Trump
crazy hasn't stopped then Donald Trump
had a massive eruption eruption careful
that's the not using a different word he
had a huge eruption where he threatened
his own campaign manager with a lawsuit
what made Trump lose his mind it is some
of those polls I recently told you about
the fact that Trump is losing to Joe
Biden in a bunch of recent polls this
includes in the general election this
includes a couple polls out of Florida
one poll out of Texas one poll out of
North Carolina so this was not a good
seven days for Donald Trump last
Thursday Trump wondered aloud about
injecting bleach to treat coronavirus
instantly going globally viral and
making him yet again the butt of jokes
and a complete and total laughingstock
Friday he bails on a press briefing
without taking a single question clearly
to avoid questions about those bleach
injection statements and then he ends up
Friday evening on a phone call with his
campaign manager Brad parse kale and
Trump went off on parse scale for the
bad poll numbers according to three
people familiar with this phone call
Trump threatened to sue his own campaign
manager for what it's not exactly clear
neither the White House nor the Trump
campaign have put out any comment about
these reports neither the White House
nor the Trump campaign have denied the
report which tells us a lot about what
we need to know one republican close to
the White House said Trump is angry
because he knows he messed up the
briefings apparently Trump started to
become irate about polling last
Wednesday night when his campaign
manager and other advisors sat him down
and they said listen the polls don't
look good in a lot of these states many
of these are important battleground
states that you probably need
and they confronted him about how his
briefings seemed to be hurting him
Thursday Trump drops the bleach bomb and
things completely implode again advisers
go to trump and say you are you are
hurting yourself with these press
briefings Friday Trump goes absolutely
nuts walking out of the press briefing
room without taking a single question
hours later getting on the phone with
his campaign manager and threatening to
sue the guy so listen this is not funny
it's not been funny for a long time
Trump is very much unwell
this is a sick individual the
coronavirus handling has been a disaster
we've already shot past the death toll
that Donald Trump preemptively bragged
would be where we end up of 60,000 now
Trump starts talking about 65 well we're
gonna be there in a few days and we're
gonna blow past that as well and we have
to worry about can Trump handle this is
Trump having another breakdown is he
emotionally stable we learned a couple
of days ago that Trump is often watching
that this is not a typo Trump is
watching five to seven hours of TV a day
before going to work around noon or
later rage tweeting as he watches TV
this is not a president this is a
petulant child
Trump has wondered about nuking
hurricanes nuclear weapons on hurricanes
Trump suggested the u.s. look at buying
Greenland Trump talked about injecting
bleach hitting the body with light as he
said and on and on and on and I get it
that there's an element of comic relief
to this when I see this next clip I
can't help but laugh this is video from
earlier this week or under this
Dickenson Howe logic and cephei sefa
Hyde I get it it's hard not to laugh at
that but this is a perfect storm of bad
ideas combined with incipient arrogance
limited reading ability and a
personality problem if not a personality
disorder and when you look at it in
total there's really nothing funny about
it you know Cobb feffy have sefa hide
all of it individually these things are
funny I get it and I laugh and we laugh
to avoid crying quite frankly but we're
paying a big
price for this now during the pandemic
and I would truly enjoy nothing more
than seeing Donald Trump absolutely
blown out in the November election
Trump often falsely claims that he had
like the biggest win of any win in 2016
remember he lost the popular vote by
nearly three million votes I want it for
the country
I want Donald Trump absolutely crushed
in November because we need him out I
don't know that that will happen every
single vote must be gained
every single vote must be worked for but
I'm admitting to you guys on a personal
level I would take great satisfaction in
seeing Donald Trump the narcissist in
chief absolutely destroyed in a historic
Joe Biden victory in November I would
take any victory and we've got to work
hard for every single vote but this is a
man who is not well he is not well and
every single day we hear something else
about his emotional instability he has
access to nuclear weapons and he can't
even control himself enough to avoid
threatening his own campaign manager
with a lawsuit for what we don't know
because he's losing in the polls and
embarrassing himself on television it's
ugly and we'll have continued coverage
of this on the David Pakman show
Instagram page at David Pakman show make
sure to follow we'll take a quick break
and be right back there's a YouTube
channel called up flip that we're
partnering with I would love for you to
check it out I've put the link right
underneath the video make sure to
subscribe to the channel when you're
there up flip is a channel that is all
about exploring small business and what
makes a small business successful every
episode interviews an entrepreneur you
take a tour of the business and these
are not generic interviews you actually
get a really fascinating deep dive into
the history of the business the mistakes
the entrepreneur made what they learned
what motivates them what a day is like
running their business and you get all
sorts of super interesting and valuable
insight about what it's like to run that
type of small business as a business
owner myself I find up flips videos to
be endlessly intriguing even if you
don't own your own business it is
really great for a general audience it's
stuff that I think just about anybody
would find fascinating and you can check
it out by going to david pakman.com
slash up flip the link is right
underneath this video when you're there
make sure to subscribe and click the
bell for notifications